gonna be real transparent this might be
because of the jet lag but I'm pretty
sure I almost fell asleep in this movie
almost can't win them all none so the
nun is another prequel to the conjuring
wow you make a pretty solid horror film
and then you give us prequels that are
crap tat for Annabel to actually like
that one wonders the nun is the origin
story from the iconic demon from the
conjuring series which is the nun takes
place in the 50s this convent temple I'm
not really always down with my Catholic
terminology this building that houses
nuns might be possessed it might no
longer be holy so there's this priest
that sent there from the Vatican and
this nun in training who sent with him
and they're gonna investigate and after
that let the mayhem begin and the jump
scares more jump scares than mayhem yep
it's a jump scare fest you knew that
from the trailer at least a trailer was
honest with us in the trailer the girls
walking this are creepy nun behind her
you think that nuns gonna lunge at her
and then another nun lunges from the
other side you see that you know it's a
jump scare fest but at least I didn't
hide it
police are owning it is they just jump
scares this jump scares that they're not
new and you see them coming a mile away
which is usually the case with jump
scares it's just so blatantly obvious
something taps someone on the shoulder
they turn around and the cameras with
them while they're looking that way
you're like it's gonna come from behind
them that's we did that two people in
junior high they're just like ooh what
could it be something tapped me on the
toe and if it's not obvious as jump
scares it's a lot of illogic not just
lack of logic but leaps that people take
you're like how did you make that leap
not that you were wrong but how ill
logic in the sense this person is buried
in this little box and they light a
lighter and I'm like burning oxygen
that's smart and again this is the 50s
it's common knowledge now maybe it
wasn't back then I wasn't alive ever
back to the future to Marty McFly's like
I know CPR and someone says what's CPR
we learned things fast in this world so
maybe he didn't know that maybe thought
he could pray for more oxygen I don't
know what is there's this one crypt with
a bunch of books he's like maybe those
books can help us or the dude just got
buried with his journals why would you
think those books would help you now
that he was wrong but still elite and
personally I just thought the characters
were bland I wasn't interested in them I
will say for young very far
Mika if I was gonna cash young Vera
Farmiga that's the girl I would cast so
while editing this someone on IMDB and
found out that's actually very far
McGee's younger sister so it totally
makes sense as to why she was cast and I
just woke up I look like [ __ ] that's why
you're getting this audio fill in rather
than video whatever back to the reveal
although that everyone just comes across
as bland except this one dude they call
him Frenchie when you first meet him he
comes across like Pepe LePew like yeah
how's it going yeah beautiful woman
doesn't talk with that thick of an
accent but you get it he was just
cartoony but as the movie goes on you
accept his cartoony nature he kind of
comes across as brenden fraiser light
that's brendan fraiser from the mummy
but in the world were the audience I was
watching this movie with was laughing
pretty hard in certain scenes those
certain scenes being the scenes that
were trying to be very serious and he
came across as cheesy because imagine an
eight-year-old wrote a script now
imagine adults have to deliver the lines
in that script with all the drama that
is becoming of a serious scene just
comes across as hokey at least this one
dude was like I know it's cheesy and I'm
gonna commit to it so he was like I'll
kind of be a cheesy quasi comedic
roguish character and it kind of makes
him a standout in this movie I thought
it worked it's not like he saves the
movie generally speaking the movie is
just boring it's boring because you've
just seen all of it before a cross on
the walls turning upside down scene it
dark shadowy figure down the hallway
saying it and you can literally count
you can clock the jump-scare at three to
one there actually was a thing or two
plot wise I enjoyed but it kind of goes
into spoiler territory so can't not hear
I appreciated that appreciated the
attempt but again the movies just it was
too far gone at that point as in the end
than none it was useless it was useless
in the sense that it's just if you want
a better version of this movie it's
somewhere out there at least a version
of it this movies like a Franken [ __ ]
and amalgamation of a few different
horror movies and everything they've
stitched into this movie was done in
another movie and it was done better
this movie made me think back to the
conjuring just how parrot was it wanted
to be a legit cool scary horror movie
that for the most part used simplicity
it's a demon terrorizing a family it's
pretty simple this goes way over the top
at the origin story at the CGI the crack
in the ground something's coming out of
it which is completely ripped off from
Hellboy I'm just saying it's not the
worst I've seen but I'm just not gonna
remember this one at t-minus one day yep
already forgot I saw the nun have you
seen it what do you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]